Un collège dans l'Yonne,
comme il en existe
des milliers d'autres en France.
Julien Malherbe a choisi d'enseigner
en zone d'éducation prioritaire.
Ici, tout le monde le connaît,
c'est le professeur
d'histoire de la troisième un.
Toutefois, sa renommée,
il la doit à Star Wars.
Dans cette classe unique en France,
on apprend l'histoire
avec les Jedi et Dark Vador,
les personnages mythiques de la saga.
-On va commencer
le projet Star Wars.
On va s'intéresser aux liens particuliers,
que peuvent avoir Star Wars
avec les régimes totalitaires.
Les deux personnages auxquels
on va s'intéresser, c'est Hitler
et l'Empereur Palpatine.
-Palpatine, l'Empereur
du mal dans Star Wars.
Un dictateur qui fait régner
la terreur tout comme Hitler.
-Le moment que
nous attendions est venu.
Exécutez l'ordre 66.
-Dans Star Wars au moment
où Palpatine va lancer l'ordre 66,
quel mot vous avez retenu ?
-Palpatine dit qu'il va
exterminer et traquer les Jedi.
-Si on dit que Palpatine,
c'est Hitler, alors c'est qui les Jedi ?
-Finalement, Palpatine,
si on fait simple, égale Hitler,
mais qui sont les Jedi ?
-La moitié de la classe n'a vu
aucun des films de George Lucas.
Cela ne pose aucun
problème aux professeurs.
Cet inconditionnel s'autorise même
quelques libertés avec le programme.
-Vous leur parlez,
par exemple, des Ewoks.
Ils connaissent tous les Ewoks.
On ne sait pas que c'est dans Star Wars...
-On n'est pas trop fan.
D'abord,
on ne les connait pas tous.
-Vous ne rêviez pas d'en avoir
un dans votre chambre ?
Non.
-Moi, je voulais en avoir dans mon lit.
Mes parents n'ont pas voulu,
mais je rêvais d'avoir ça.
-Le projet peut paraître un peu farfelu,
mais les résultats sont là,
la classe est beaucoup plus attentive.
-On s'est rendu compte
avec les collègues
que les élèves qui étaient
souvent les plus en retrait,
les élèves les plus en difficulté
avaient une nouvelle dynamique de travail.
Ils s'inspiraient plus de ce qu'on faisait
en classe et étaient davantage motivés.
Clairement, Star Wars peut aider
les zones d'éducation prioritaire.
-Deux heures plus tard,
les élèves ont retenu la leçon.
-Que la force soit avec vous !
-Bientôt dans les salles,
la suite de la plus grande
aventure spatiale du cinéma.
Les premières images
de la bande-annonce ont été visionnées
68 millions de fois sur YouTube.
Signe que la fièvre de Star Wars
n'est pas prête de retomber.
-Il y en a un septième qui arrive.
C'est un truc de fou.
-Être Yoda, en tout cas,
fait partie de ces figures héroïques,
dont la société a besoin aujourd'hui.
-Avec le lancement
de cette nouvelle trilogie,
Disney,
désormais détenteur des droits,
va conquérir
une nouvelle génération de fans.
Aujourd'hui, son univers imaginaire a déjà
des impacts surprenants dans la réalité.
Comme cette école de Jedi,
un endroit unique au monde
où l'on apprend à manier le sabre laser,
une discipline qui débarque en France.
-On ne va pas se mentir, c'est super
chouette de se battre avec un sabre laser.
-La maîtrise de la force,
la méditation ou encore la connaissance,
des valeurs, que certains
disciples ont repris à leur compte
pour créer une toute nouvelle religion,
le Jediisme.
-Dans le Jediisme, il y a l'idée que
l'être vivant est motivé par la force,
par une énergie créatrice.
-Plongez dans la galaxie Star Wars.
Dans ce tout petit village,
à 45 kilomètres de Lille,
Thomas, 24 ans, incarne cette
nouvelle génération de fans de Star Wars.
-N'essaie pas.
Fais-le ou ne le fait pas.
Il n'y a pas d'essai.
-Cette voix bien connue, c'est celle
de son personnage préféré, Yoda.
Le sage de la saga
et le plus puissant des maîtres Jedi.
Depuis dix ans,
il partage sa chambre.
-Ce sont des pages
de cours d'anglais.
Quand j'avais 15 ans,
j'avais beaucoup de mal en anglais,
c'est toujours le cas,
et j'avais de la rage quand
j'avais des examens de passage.
J'arrachais les pages
de mon cours d'anglais,
et j'ai fait des bulles avec
et puis, de fil en aiguille,
j'ai fait une tête et des oreilles.
Puis, au fur et à mesure,
j'ai rajouté du plâtre
et voilà, ça a fait Yoda.
-Dans sa chambre, il a recréé
l'univers intergalactique du film.
À huit ans, il voit son premier
épisode et s'identifie aux Jedi,
ces Chevaliers de la Paix.
Depuis, il fabrique
lui-même les objets de la saga.
À chaque sortie de film,
une nouvelle création.
-Il s'appelle BB-8.
Les fans de Star Wars, l'ont découvert
lors du premier trailer de l'épisode sept.
Il apparaît seulement
à peine quelques secondes.
-L'apprenti Jedi attend surtout
le retour du Faucon Millenium,
le vaisseau mythique
piloté par Harrison Ford
et son compagnon à poil Chewbacca.
-Chew,
on est à la maison.
-Je crois que tous les fans
de Star Wars sur la planète,
quand ils ont vu la tête
de Harrison Ford et de Chewbacca,
il y en a qui étaient
totalement émerveillés,
il y en a qui crient,
il y en a qui pleurent.
Parfois,
c'est assez impressionnant.
Je suis resté bouche bée
et je n'ai plus rien dit
pendant quelques minutes.
-Ce jeune professeur de physique-chimie
vit chez ses parents, qui l'ont vu passer
du papier mâché
à la fabrication d'un sabre laser.
Aujourd'hui, il va forger
lui-même le manche de son arme.
C'est sa première tentative.
-Ça fait partie de la formation d'un
Jedi de fabriquer son propre sabre laser.
Je trouve ça chouette.
Papa, il est prêt le moule ou pas ?
Non ?
-Comme à chaque fois,
Thomas peut compter sur l'aide
de son père, le bien nommé Luc.
Pas un Jedi,
il est paysagiste.
Depuis toujours, il encourage
son fils unique dans sa passion.
-Pour moi, j'aime bien
parce que c'est une passion qui est saine.
Ça fait travailler son imagination,
alors chaque semaine,
on découvre une surprise.
-C'est un meilleur bricoleur que moi,
mais c'est vrai que,
je suis peut-être plus doué
pour tout ce qui
est électronique, etc.
-On peut dire que je finance aussi
ces expériences parce qu'en fin de compte,
ça coûte toutes ces expériences.
-C'est maintenant que cela va se jouer.
Le four a atteint 400 degrés,
la bonne température pour forger.
-Papa, tu peux amener
le moule, s'il te plaît ?
-Seulement, aujourd'hui,
la force n'est pas avec eux.
-Ne mets pas la pâte au dessus.
-Le professeur de physique
a raté son coup.
-La chaleur n'est pas assez forte
pour pouvoir faire fondre le tout,
donc, j'ai eu
un beau bouchon en fait.
Ce n'est pas grave.
Un précepte du code Jedi dit,
« Il n'y a pas d'ignorance,
il y a la connaissance. »
C'est en faisant
des erreurs qu'on apprend.
-Si l'apprenti n'arrive pas
encore à forger son manche,
il a déjà assemblé plusieurs sabres
avec des matériaux de récupération.
Celui-ci a été fabriqué
avec des pièces d'un vieil aspirateur.
Après six mois de travail,
voici la réplique
du sabre de maître Yoda.
-Il y a des détecteurs de choc.
Il y a aussi
des capteurs de mouvements.
Il y a aussi les parades de tirs
de blaster, donc le pistolaser.
Ça, c'est juste pour le fun.
-L'Univers de George Lucas est aussi
en train de conquérir le monde du sport.
Jusque-là, l'arme des Jedi
était un simple jouet.
Aujourd'hui, le sabre laser est en train
de devenir un art martial à part entière.
En mai dernier, la toute première
Coupe d'Europe a rassemblé 135 Jedi.
Les chevaliers s'affrontent
dans un tournoi bien réel.
Une discipline
qui séduit de plus en plus.
Milan, Dublin, Stockholm,
16 académies ont déjà ouvert
leurs portes en Europe.
À Paris, Ludovic rêve d'ouvrir
la première école en France.
Cet agent de sécurité de 32 ans
est un grand fan de Star Wars.
Ce projet un peu fou,
il le partage avec Angela,
sa compagne australienne depuis deux ans.
Ça va ?
-Oui et toi ?
-Oui, ça va.
-Il rêve d'avoir une Académie pour
apprendre des choses dans le Star Wars.
-C'était le rêve de petit garçon.
Je ne sais plus qui a dit ça,
qu'il fallait rêver grand
pour pouvoir ne pas perdre,
ses rêves de vue en grandissant.
Alors, je me suis dit,
« Moi, je serai un Jedi. »
-Pour devenir de vrais Jedi,
le couple va
s'en donner les moyens.
Ce soir,
ils partent suivre
une formation de dix jours en Italie.
À la clé, un diplôme remis
par les grands maîtres du sabre laser.
-C'est le stage
pour devenir instructeur.
C'est ce qui me permettra
d'ouvrir l'école à Paris,
qu'on va tous les deux le passer.
Comme ça, on aura déjà
deux instructeurs dès le début.
-Si vous n'arrivez pas à l'avoir ?
-Il n'y a pas d'école
ou il faudra qu'un d'autre,
un français de Paris
le passe et fasse l'école.
On va bien travailler pour.
-Oui, on va bien travailler pour.
-Moi, ma valise,
elle est prête.
-Si ça marche,
ils vont quitter leur travail
et changer de vie.
-Go Ninja, go ninja !
-Pour réduire les frais de voyage,
Ludovic et Angela partent en bus,
car l'école de Jedi a un coût,
2 000 euros par apprenti.
Douze heures de trajet,
1 300 kilomètres
jusqu'à Avigliano Umbro
au centre de l'Italie.
À l'abri des regards,
dans un village médiéval d'Ombrie,
se trouve l'Académie des Jedi,
une école unique au monde.
C'est là que sont formés
les futurs apôtres.
Depuis une semaine,
Ludovic, Angela
et une trentaine d'élèves triés sur
le volet s'entraînent, du matin au soir
à manier le sabre laser.
-Tu bouges comme ça.
-Antonio est un
des instructeurs de l'Académie.
Au classement mondial,
c'est le numéro trois.
-On a imaginé ça
comme un sport de combat,
un vrai sport de combat.
On ne fait pas de la chorégraphie
comme dans Star Wars.
Chaque mouvement,
chaque attaque doit être efficace.
-Comme le héros de Star Wars,
le jeune Luke Skywalker,
Ludovic et Angela
apprennent le Shii-Cho,
l'un des sept styles
de combat de la saga.
-C'est le premier style
que Luc Skywalker a appris,
avec Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Pendant le combat avec Dark Vador
dans l'Empire contre-attaque,
vous pouvez voir des mouvements
qui rappellent un petit peu le Shii-Cho.
-Même à des centaines de kilomètres,
l'existence de cette école
n'a pas échappé à Thomas.
Lui aussi va passer
son diplôme d'instructeur,
mais contrairement à Ludovic,
il est surtout là pour s'amuser.
-Quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait une école de
sabre laser qui allait ouvrir ses portes,
j'ai explosé, je me suis
dit, ce n'est pas possible.
Directement, j'ai foncé
sur l'occasion et puis voilà.
C'est une aventure de dingue.
Ce n'est pas de la chorégraphie
ou des choses comme ça.
Non, c'est vraiment
un sport de combat.
Je ne sais pas trop
à quoi m'attendre.
Il y avait des sabres laser, pour moi,
de toute façon, ça va être génial.
C'est encore mieux
que ce que je pensais.
-Pendant les duels,
ça ne rigole pas.
Les Jedi s'imaginent que leur lame
est un vrai laser, comme dans le film.
C'est même la règle
principale de ce sport.
"Oh ", une touche mortelle.
Un laser tranche
tout ce qu'il touche.
" Hi ", une blessure
ou une simple amputation.
Trois coups dans les parties vitales,
c'est fini, Antonio a gagné.
Avant d'arriver
à ce niveau de combat,
Ludovic va devoir s'entraîner dur.
Son mentor, Daniele,
le prépare pour son examen de Jedi.
C'est un bon élève, Ludovic ?
-Oui.
Il a beaucoup d'expérience
avec les arts martiaux,
et je pense que ça lui donne
l'habilité d'être très réactif,
très capable d'observer l'adversaire.
-Daniele, il est bon,
ça fait longtemps qu'il en fait.
Je veux bien avoir quelqu'un
qui a l'œil pour corriger les défauts.
-Huit heures d'entraînement
intensif par jour,
une formalité pour Ludovic.
Pour Thomas,
c'est une autre histoire.
-J'ai mal partout.
Je ne suis pas si sportif que ça.
Ici, c'est dix jours très intensifs
et je n'ai plus de jambes.
C'est vraiment...
-Ici, toutes les journées se ressemblent.
Après l'entraînement,
place aux révisions.
Ce soir, c'est veille
d'examens pour Ludovic et Angela.
Dix jours de cours théoriques
à connaître par cœur,
et pour compliquer la tâche,
les termes du combat sont en italien.
-Fais voir un " Sinistro. "
-C'est une attaque sur le côté gauche.
-Oui.
Ok !
" Otaba. "
-Tu sors, tu fais une rime,
tu sors et tu prends
la lame de l'adversaire vers le bas.
-Le couple n'a pas le droit à l'erreur.
S'ils échouent leur projet
d'école ne verra pas le jour.
-Vous pensez bien maîtriser
ces techniques pour l'instant
ou vous êtes serein ?
-Non, serein, non.
Il n'y a pas d'excès de confiance.
Il faut qu'on travaille.
On a encore toute la soirée
et encore un peu de temps demain matin.
-Il y a un risque d'échouer là-bas ?
-Il y a toujours un risque.
C'est pour cela, qu'on est venu à deux,
comme ça, on a une chance sur deux.
-À la nuit tombée,
la nature chevaleresque
des élèves se réveille.
Leur académie se transforme
en zone de combat,
où s'affrontent Jedi et Sith,
ces soldats du mal armés de sabres rouges.
Dans la peau
d'un chevalier de la Paix,
Thomas affronte
le côté obscur de la Force,
et vit un rêve éveillé.
Pour de nombreux admirateurs,
les Jedi sont plus
que de simples combattants.
Ils incarnent un modèle spirituel.
À tel point qu'une religion
inspirée des films est née.
La réalité a dépassé la fiction
pour la première fois en Angleterre.
En 2001, des centaines de milliers
de Britanniques se sont déclarés Jedi
dans le recensement national.
-En Angleterre, aujourd'hui,
il y a 180 000 personnes
qui se sont proclamées Jedi.
Dans le recensement à la case religion,
ils ont inscrit Chevalier Jedi.
-Je dois vous dire
que c'est seulement un film.
Non Hermann.
-Non ?
-C'est un système
de croyance très profond.
C'est la religion que nous suivons.
Pour nous,
c'est entièrement réel.
-Les pratiquants
se nomment les jedistes.
Difficile de connaître leur nombre,
mais ils seraient plus
de 500 000 dans le monde.
Les adeptes sont encore
peu nombreux en France.
Cet été, à Metz,
des dizaines de jedistes
ont défilé derrière Yoda,
le plus mystique des personnages
de Star Wars, érigé ici en chef religieux.
Une parodie de procession
pour demander que la religion Jedi,
soit reconnue en Alsace-Lorraine.
-Là où il y a la passion,
il y a la sérénité.
Là où il y a le chao,
il y a l'harmonie.
Là où il y a la mort,
il y a la force.
-Frédéric est jediste depuis huit ans.
Comme tous les fidèles,
il alimente sa foi de sermons
postés par les maîtres sur Internet.
Un temple virtuel.
Le seul moyen pour les adeptes
de pratiquer leur religion.
Alexandre Orion est
le pasteur du Temple de l'Ordre Jedi.
Le premier texte
qu'il enseigne, c'est le code.
L'équivalent des dix commandements.
-Il n'y a pas d'émotion,
il y a la paix.
Il n'y a pas d'ignorance,
il y a la connaissance.
-C'est une région sans Dieu,
sans être divin, sans être supérieur.
Il n'y a pas d’interdictions
comme dans les religions monothéistes.
Il y a une liberté d'être soi-même.
Vous croyez en quoi ?
-On croit en la force.
-Ce soir, Frédéric
reçoit deux amis fans de la saga.
Salut.
-Salut, ça va ?
-C'est un rituel.
Avant un nouveau Star Wars,
ils regardent tous les anciens volets.
Si pour Jonathan et Frank,
c'est l'occasion de replonger en enfance,
pour Frédéric,
l'expérience est plus spirituelle.
Les répliques du film
résonnent comme une prophétie.
-Il y a quand même un texte
fondateur qui est le film, on va dire.
Puisqu'on a les paroles de Maître Yoda,
donc, on a du texte.
-Je vais essayer.
-Non.
N'essaie pas.
Fais-le ou ne le fais pas.
Il n'y a pas d'essai.
-C'est sur ce genre de répliques
que repose le Jediisme.
Un mélange aux ingrédients
un peu indigestes.
D'abord, un peu de Freud.
-C'est très psychanalytique.
-Une pincée de mythologie,
une cuillère de bouddhisme.
-On retrouve l'essence
même du bouddhisme zen.
-Une bonne louche de christianisme.
-C'est là où ça me fait
penser au Christ qui, finalement,
face à Ponce Pilate,
il préfère baisser sa garde.
-Il n'est pas prêt.
-Dans ce méli-mélo,
Jonathan s'y retrouve.
Il ne croit pas en la force,
mais s'identifie aux valeurs des Jedi.
-Le film est une leçon de vie,
c'est une leçon de philosophie
qu'on appelle
une philosophie ou une religion,
mais qu'ils aillent vers ce mode
de fonctionnement, ne m'étonne pas.
-C'est là où on voit
que Star Wars est plus qu'un film.
Ça participe à ce qu'on peut
appeler un mythe contemporain.
-En Italie,
dans l'Académie des Jedi,
c'est le grand jour.
Dans quelques minutes,
Angela et Ludovic vont
être jugés par leur maître.
-Bonne chance à tous !
-Sans oublier le traditionnel
cri de ralliement
annonçant le début des épreuves.
-Un bon, en ciel !
-En une demi-heure,
une trentaine
d'apprentis Jedi sont jaugés.
Angela va être testée
sur son point faible, le combat.
Le maître ne lui fait pas de cadeau.
-Plus agressif, Angela.
Plus agressif.
-Ludovic, lui,
est interrogé sur la théorie.
-S'il te plaît, montre-moi
tous les mouvements du Shii Cho.
-La position de jambe,
c'est la position de garde.
-Les maîtres le savent,
sa faille, c'est la pédagogie.
Dans la peau d'un instructeur, l'élève
doit rassurer sur sa capacité à enseigner.
-Rester en haut.
Tu montes et quand il est ici,
il ne faut pas le pousser
effectivement en étant un peu trop bas.
-À l'issue de sa prestation,
le doute s'installe.
-Ce n'était pas parfait,
je ne suis pas totalement content,
mais ça devrait, ça devrait aller.
-Après une demi-journée d'examen
et quelques heures de délibérations,
le jury va rendre son verdict.
Dans le groupe,
l'ambiance est plutôt tendue.
L'an dernier,
40 % des élèves ont échoué
et ça commence mal.
-Giorgio Santi.
Tu n'as pas réussi l'examen.
Luc.
Tu n'as pas réussi non plus.
-C'est au tour des deux Français.
-Vous avez réussi l'examen.
Vous avez été très
bon en tant qu'équipe.
Ludovic,
tu es un athlète très physique.
D'un autre côté, Angela,
toi, tu as une grande capacité
de communication
et tu es très délicate.
-Le couple a passé l'examen avec brio.
Un soulagement
après des mois de préparation.
Thomas devient aussi,
instructeur aujourd'hui.
-Thomas, tu as réussi aussi.
-Cette année,
la moitié des élèves ont été reçus.
Pour les Français,
c'est la promesse d'une nouvelle vie.
Ça représente quoi pour vous ?
-C'est le premier pas.
Avec le diplôme,
on va pouvoir ouvrir l'École de Paris.
Ça commence.
-Dans son village,
au Nord de Lille,
Thomas s'est levé aux aurores.
Le sabre laser ne lui suffit pas.
Aujourd'hui, il va
se glisser dans la peau d'un Jedi.
-On fait le tri
de ce que tu prends.
-Avec Cassandre,
sa compagne depuis deux ans,
ils partagent la passion du cosplay.
Les costumes de science-fiction.
-Moi, je ne suis plus
à fabriquer les masques en latex,
tout ce qui est armure.
Tandis que Cassandre...
-Je me suis occupé de la couture,
donc tout ce qui est veste ou toge Jedi.
Pour Thomas aussi les guêtres.
Tout ce qui est plus matériau
compliqué, ça, je te le laisse.
-C'est parti pour
40 minutes de maquillage.
Pour les néophytes,
ça ne saute pas aux yeux,
mais Cassandre est déguisée en Jedi.
Un alien nommé Kit Fisto qui apparaît
dans la série “La Guerre des clowns”.
Ils ont mis six mois
à confectionner les costumes.
Dans quelques heures,
le couple montera sur scène
pour un grand concours de cosplay.
-Si vous n'avez pas aimé
Star Wars, ce n'est pas grave.
Tu m'aurais juste quitté ?
-Non, pas du tout.
C'est un plus,
on a une passion commune.
Je crois que ça renforce
un peu plus notre couple.
-Super génial !
Magnifique Cassandre !
-C'est la première fois,
que la mère de Thomas voit les costumes
et Cassandre fait son petit effet.
-C'est du lourd
avec les munitions et tout.
-C'est incroyable, j'adore.
-Direction Gand en Belgique,
à plus d'une heure et demie de route.
Sur le trajet,
le convoi ne passe pas inaperçu.
Surtout Cassandre.
Des aliens sur la banquette arrière.
-Après 800 mètres,
prendre la sortie du droit,
puis à gauche, je te dis, tu devrais...
-Dans le GPS,
la voix de maître Yoda,
mais le guide des Jedi
n'est pas d'un grand secours pour Luc.
-À gauche ou droite ?
-Concentre-toi.
-À droite, on ne va nulle part.
À gauche ?
-Avant de rentrer dans le salon,
Thomas se transforme en Jedi.
Il sera le général Ima-Gun Di,
un héros de la Guerre des clowns.
-J'espère qu'on va gagner
quand même un petit prix.
-La F.A.C.T.S,
c'est le plus grand rassemblement
des fans de science-fiction en Belgique.
Le temple de la Culture Geek visité
par 40 000 personnes chaque année.
-On a l'impression que
l'on commence à rentrer dans un film.
-Pour les fans de Star Wars,
c'est l'événement à ne pas rater.
Ici, tout le monde
connaît Kit Fisto et Ima-Gun Di.
À peine arrivés,
ils font sensation.
Sur son passage, Cassandre
fait même tourner les têtes.
À chaque pas, ils sont
arrêtés par des mordus de la saga.
Bonjour.
-J'adore vos costumes.
Merci.
-Ça vous intéresse une photo.
Bien sûr.
-On peut se coucher dessus ?
-Que des filles, donc toi, tu peux.
-Cette grosse limace, c'est Jabba,
un seigneur du crime bien connu des fans.
Une photo collector
dans un décor officiel signé
de la main même de George Lucas.
-C'est terrible.
-J'ai des choses très intéressantes,
j'ai la photo du moment où il a signé.
-C'est bien la preuve que c'est lui.
-Encore un privilège accordé.
Normalement, personne n'est
autorisé à chevaucher cet engin rouillé
et pour cause,
c'est la moto jet de l'épisode sept,
qu'on aperçoit quelques secondes
seulement dans la bande-annonce.
C'est l'heure du défilé de cosplay
devant des centaines
de spectateurs avertis.
Juste avant de monter sur scène,
Cassandre a un petit problème.
Sa peinture s'écaille.
-Ne t'inquiète pas, ça va aller.
-Tu mets une couche.
-C'est le plus grand concours auquel
le couple ait participé jusqu'à présent.
Cela fait des semaines
qu'ils travaillent leur chorégraphie.
Devant les juges,
ils devront faire sans faute.
Des Jedi qui dansent
sur du Michael Jackson.
Personne n'avait encore jamais vu ça.
-C'était bien.
-Vous avez vraiment bien fait ça.
-Félicitations.
Merci.
-Super.
-On sentait que Cassandre
a un peu stressé sur la fin.
-Oui, c'est le bout
de chorégraphie que je connaissais.
-Un petit détail
qui a échappé aux juges.
Thomas et Cassandre remportent,
le prix du meilleur costume en équipe
sur 40 participants.
-Un petit bisou.
C'est mon nez ça.
-Six mois de travail
pour cinq minutes de show.
Le couple pense
déjà au prochain costume.
Comme des millions de fans,
il attend avec impatience
la sortie de l'épisode sept,
pour se mettre dans
la peau des nouveaux Jedi.